[Musique]
ans
c'est vous
[Musique]
bon
c'était tellement bien le trait qui
était vraiment magique vraiment ça je me
suis vraiment attaché au porteur c'est
vrai qu'on les connaissait pas et jamais
j'aurais pensé venir faire un voyage et
avoir cette complicité avec les porteurs
nous demander tout le temps si on allait
bien c'était vraiment magique et il
était tellement gentil adorable et je
suis vraiment contente de ce voyage
c'est magnifique déjà c'est
incroyable et c'est vrai qu'on était
entourée de montagnes on se sentait
petit mais c'était tellement calme
c'était apaisant on entendait les
oiseaux
c'était magique et moi je pense qu'il
m'a marqué c'est ma le sommet qu'on a
fait
4400 mètres c'est énorme moi je suis
fier de tout le monde parce qu'on de
tout ce qu'on a pu accomplir pendant ce
trek franchement c'est magique
[Musique]
et
tu es beaucoup de dénivelés beaucoup de
montées après à la fast et beaucoup de
descentes mais c'était très fatigant
mais maintenant c'est fini et le voyage
humain s'est très vite lui portèrent
j'en ai je savais pas que ça existait et
les ânes qui porte les sacs les ânes
comme ça dans la nature les yaks je
connaissais pas que ça existait plainte
choisi
[Musique]
bonjour je suis hyper contente d'être
arrivée ici mais
s'annonce vraiment la fin la fin la fin
du trech presque la fin de voyage et je
suis hyper triste qu'ils étaient tous et
tous ces gens merveilleux qu'on a
rencontré ces visages qu'on a vu que ça
va nous porter nos sherpas
dawa sonam enfin jp reprise de l'équité
mais bon ça fait plaisir quand même de
rentrer un peu à la maison détient
[Musique]
plus
c
[Musique]
ans
e
oh